but when i realized that tick tock is
like super bowl sunday it's like you've
got a billion people on this platform
and you've got a couple seconds to put a
message out there and what i realized
was that once i started putting out
little bite-sized pieces of my content
one i went viral like at least once a
month and i started reaching way more
people faster organically
did you know that tiktok has over 1
billion active monthly users and 90 of
those users are logging in every single
day
that is insane when you think about the
ability to reach your target audience to
reach the people you want to help
through a video platform tick-tock is
something you should not be sleeping on
we're talking about all that and more in
today's episode on the think media
podcast welcome to the think media
podcast my name is heather torres i'm
your host of this show where we're
helping you build your influence on
youtube and then turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
online business and today's video is
brought to you by grow with video live
we are in the countdown to the number
one conference to grow your personal
brand using video and i cannot wait to
see you in person in las vegas in just a
few short days it's going to be such an
incredible experience with speakers and
content from people like gary vaynerchuk
pat flynn
chalene johnson alex hermosie laila
hermosi jasmine star aaron on demand
heather torres sean cannell omar alta
corey so many people are going to be a
part of this crazy experience you're
going to have people in the room from
newbies all the way to eight figure
earners and i cannot wait for you to get
in that room at
growesvideolive2022. you can secure your
ticket for our in-person or a virtual
experience at growwithvideolive.com
now over the last year think media has
actually started a tick tock account yes
i know it feels like we've been sleeping
on it but we are youtube experts and now
we have grown our team and grown our
influence to the point where we know we
need to not be sleeping on tick tock and
what's crazy is that over the last few
months we've had some viral tick tock uh
videos and we've learned so much about
what works on the platform but today
sean's gonna be having a conversation
with one of the tick tock experts to
help you learn how to grow your tik-tok
account right now you're going to learn
the best practices and not just how to
make great videos because even though
that's awesome i want you to be making
sales so you're going to learn how to
actually turn those videos into direct
sales for your business all that and
more is coming up in today's featured
conversation
[Music]
so what is happening with tick-tock and
especially as youtube creators should we
be embracing really the largest platform
right now recent stats revealed that
it's getting more traffic than google
well i'm excited because in this episode
of the podcast i'm talking to kenya
kelly who actually really helps
entrepreneurs generate sales for their
courses and their coaching using
tick-tock she resides in sunny san diego
we're here at a conference together
she's incredible and in just a bit we're
going to get into five ways to sell on
tick tock um but let's kick it off with
um what's who are you in a nutshell and
um why tick tock like what is the
opportunity there for sure so i am a
business owner i teach people how to
make money in the business i'm also a
very fun loving type of person and when
i think about tick tock like
granted two years ago i was not on tick
tock but i got started there as a way to
kind of like i thought it was more so
entertainment based but when i realized
that tick tock is like super bowl sunday
it's like you've got a billion people on
this platform and you've got a couple
seconds to put a message out there and
what i realized was that once i started
putting out little bite-sized pieces of
my content one i went viral like at
least once a month and i started
reaching way more people faster
organically wow and i the numbers
continue to grow there you know we
actually have we're kind of late to the
game but the organic reach is still
incredible yeah we started official
think media on tick tock and i recently
had my my first uh talk go
viral it got like 770 000 views and it
was just like a clip of a talk that i
did and i think team's been just
chopping up content we're experimenting
but we're excited to learn the tips i'm
curious though what's new on tick tock i
just got an announcement that i can
upload five minute videos now but i've
heard some accounts get 15 minute videos
10 i have 10 minutes we just got 10
minute videos yes and it's up to 15 for
some yeah yes that's that's insane so i
think a lot of people's brains are
breaking mine included because it's like
is it short form is it long form what's
happening like what are some of the
other things happening with tiktok and
what's your take on video length with
some of the where the platform's going
for sure i think that well one as a
business with tick tock like their job
is to constantly be growing and being
evolving and we also know that top time
on platform and with a billion people
now on the platform and more people
going there that people will spend more
time watching videos if they're if
they're longer potentially kind of like
what happens with youtube and i think
that with tick-tock's you know goal to
always be the number one like who was
number one google and youtube and so
their job is to keep people from sending
their audience to youtube and keep them
on the tik tok platform and i think
that's it's a brilliant strategy now do
i think that it will be violently
opposed absolutely it already is because
people are used to these 15 second clips
but those of us that really understand
business and marketing it's amazing
because we're able to
have people watch our 15 second videos
and our long-form content and we like we
develop these massive communities even
faster but also serve them even the more
so i think it's great what's the longest
video you've uploaded on tick tock
two and a half minutes okay yeah got it
yeah are you gonna try to push one to
ten to test or like what um i think that
cause we're actually launching our
youtube channel like really doing it i
think that once we get some um good
video footage then we'll start we'll
start chopping things up and putting on
tick tock right now eventually but right
now our audience they don't really like
it they don't really respond to my
longer videos so i'm like okay i have to
slowly ease them into it but i do think
over the next 90 days i will upload
something that's like five to seven
minutes sure i love it well i'm excited
to uh talk about five ways to sell on
tick tock and again we really serve
business-minded content creators on the
think media podcast and and really
believe that even for maybe someone that
doesn't even know what their business is
yet that they want to be thinking more
like a business owner which eventually
means you can probably have some kind of
an offer
um and a lot of times you don't think
that you can sell on social media but
you say that you can and you you shared
five things the first one's live
streaming yeah i don't know if people
know you can live stream on tick tock
talk a little bit about this yeah so
live streaming is amazing now you have
to have 1 000 followers on tick tock in
order to be able to live stream and you
have to be 16 years of age just fyi and
if you're if you are an older person and
you have a kid don't put your kid in
your live stream because you get banned
just want to say that really quickly but
with live stream it's um it's just like
when you were live streaming on facebook
and instagram except you find way more
people enjoying your lives on tick tock
than they do anywhere one because when
you go live of course it alerts everyone
that's currently following you but then
there's like a live feed button that if
you click on it you're going to see tick
tock is pushing out live feed content
just in general
but also with the top time on platform
now like when i go live if my audience
starts tapping and just liking my
numbers will like skyrocket with the
amount of people that are joining my
life so oftentimes on my live stream not
only am i like talking and teaching but
usually there's products behind me
there's something up on the screen with
a link to something and so if i'm just
serving my audience teaching they can
see books in the background they can see
links and i have found my numbers of
selling and opt-ins have just
drastically increased because of
livestream wow and that's that's super
smart that gives into
another one of your tips which is
product placement so talk a little bit
about that for sure so we all know that
when we watch a movie there's like the
pepsi logo or coke logo and for me what
happened was like a year and a half ago
i was just doing a regular video i was
actually being a little bit petty if i
could be honest and i just picked up my
book for like a half but like a minute
maybe no like a really short second and
within like days i'm watching my books
just sell like crazy and it's like a
business book so i was kind of like what
is happening and then on amazon and
kendall it just was blowing up and when
i went look back at that video that
video was at a million views i said oh
my god it was just me showing it
but then i intentionally like designed
my office to have my books behind me and
so when i shoot my tick tock videos you
can always see my book there i always
spot the comments will say what is the
name of that book and so then i'll write
it in the comments and i pin it boom i
sell books like crazy wow wow what's
what is the name of your book it's
called before you quit your job okay
great and and then the cover is
recognizable and people can go right
over to amazon and buy whatever format
is my picture yes for sure that is
brilliant in fact as i think about you
know i gotta have youtube secrets in the
uh you know more intentionally as
product placement and just consistently
behind or on screen super super wise um
all right the next one uh your bio yes
and so recently i think we saw the
biggest jump in traffic when i got
almost a million views and i got i went
to my analytics and tick tock and got 11
000 profile visits which was really cool
and i mean that was collective over
however length of time so so what is
kind of your bio strategy and talk about
this tip for sure so one of the things
about we know about video marketing is
that with tick tock if you once you post
one video they they don't really know
you but you're on the for you feed which
is a feed where tick tock is pushing out
content well if they decide i really
like you and i want to see more from you
well they're going to click on your your
your name and then it's going to take
them to your page now sometimes people
read your bio sometimes they won't but
like as soon as they get the first thing
they see is your photo and then they see
who you are what your account is about
and so i teach business owners that
don't make people guess tell them who
you are and what it is that you do so in
my bio i say this is who i am it's who i
serve and then of course i have these
down arrows that are pointing to the
link in my bio and so if they have liked
my piece of business content and they
kind of want more from me and they click
that link in my bio then of course it's
now that there's my product but i make
sure that my bio it doesn't say i'm a
cat lover i'm single it says i help x
with a b and c so when she comes to my
page she knows i'm talking to her and i
can help her and i'm able to sell more
products to my ideal client and what's
in your bio right now what's where does
it lead uh if someone clicks the link in
your bio for sure so the first thing it
leads to is a free tic topper business
like cheat sheet and training uh and
then it leads to our tick-tock a
business course and then it leads to our
book awesome yeah amazing all right the
third one is is direct sales so how do
you do direct sales on tick-tock for
sure so it's kind of like you know we
all know how to like just talk into the
camera and sell and so that's what i'm
telling someone so it's not like i don't
just say buy my courses call a b and c
but i'm literally teaching whatever it
is that i'm teaching and at the end of
the video i'm saying for more of this to
learn about this just go to the link in
my bio or click on my profile and you
can purchase our course so i'm directly
saying purchase my product versus just
having a product placement yeah so just
being really clear yes and uh and not
hesitating to be direct and you've added
value first though that's for sure yes
always add value first because you know
people people are going to watch your
video because they're getting something
from it because tick tock is more of an
entertainment platform so and then just
any anyway we all love to be sold to
like as in like served and sold so yeah
so serve first
and then another one of your tips is
trends what do you mean by that yeah so
we everybody has seen the tick tock
videos where you're pointing or you're
talking with somebody's voice and so
oftentimes i will like i may see
somebody who's 16 years old doing a
trend that has nothing to do with that's
like right before i came somebody was
doing this
and it sounds really dumb but i start
teaching
like i can use a trend and say here's
how not to market your products and then
on screen you're going to see these
little words and i'm saying
not to this not to that and at the end
i'm saying do this right and so do this
could be grab the link in my profile
grab my course grab my book but it's
it's using something that tick-tock
knows it's the culture right which is
something fun or funny or entertaining
but instead of just doing goofy things
you're doing these things with the
intention
of talking to your direct ideal customer
and then leading them to what it is you
want to lead them to you know like we've
all seen these funny little goofy things
and so people think that's all you have
to do on tick tock but you're taking
this thing and go how can i relate this
to my ideal customer and then when your
customer watches as they they completely
understand like like oftentimes when i'm
teaching about business i'll talk about
like that time when i sent an email that
didn't have the clickable link in it and
i like pass out on the floor and
everyone that has sent an email can
relate to that and then if i had an
email marketing course i could sell it
with that yeah that's brilliant and i
think you just dispelled a lot of myths
that we may hold which is like okay why
dance on tick tock why point at words
why do trending audio what do trends
have to do with me as a professional
yeah but you're sort of busting that
myth and saying no if you do it
strategically and you understand what
you teach then this can actually drive
sales it can drive leads yes and it
really can ultimately grow your business
and while you're having fun at the same
time yes this might be outside of the
wheelhouse for some and we might have to
stretch ourselves a little bit to get
creative but i think the results also
speak for themselves the amount of views
and reach and potential growth that's
happening on tick tock you really don't
want to be left behind exactly i feel i
feel a lot of
positive pressure right now to say
i i i don't want to miss the organic
reach that continues to be there and
we've all lived through eras in social
media where things come and things go
but the truth is right now as people are
listening to this podcast there's still
massive opportunity on tick tock and the
organic reach is crazy yes it's shocking
i mean it's every time i see a video i'm
like i just posted that 30 minutes ago
there's 2 000 views on that i'm like 2
000 people cannot fit in my house and
i'm always just like amazed by that
because i mean if i post a video today
on facebook that's not going to happen
although i do love facebook it's just
something special is happening on the
tick tock platform and if more marketers
really understood like hey forget the
things you know just think about what's
happening with these videos more people
would would create more content there
brilliant well if people want to connect
with you uh you know you're here you're
actually given 10 uh ways to sell it
today we just covered five and you're
speaking here at social media marketing
world but you're a great follower
especially for anyone in the think media
podcast community that's ready to
add on tick tick-tock to your strategy
or embrace
vertical video and also hit up youtube
shorts tick-tock and reels so much
opportunity there but where can we find
you online and follow you and connect
with you for sure so i'm definitely on
tik-tok and everything is kia kelly so
you can find me on tick tock but if
you're not there yet then follow me on
instagram kelly i love it and check out
show notes and links uh in the
description or the podcast show notes
and we'll see in the next one
well i hope that that conversation
really sparked an interest for you to go
all in on tiktok this year and one of
the action items i want to give you is
to follow us at think media on tick tock
so you can see the latest best practices
of what we're implementing along with
getting great content that you can use
in your youtube channel and online
business so i will link down below in
the youtube description and in the show
notes if you want to follow us over on
tick tock and the next action that i
hope you take is securing your ticket to
grow with video live we are just a few
short days away from this incredible
experience and i don't want you to miss
out like i don't want you to have fomo
friend i want you to actually be in the
room i want you to experience this if i
can be honest with you i get it if you
are nervous about coming to grow with
video live not nervous because you're
not going to get the best quality let me
tell you you are going to learn some of
the best advice that can help you grow
not just this year but in over the next
decade but if you're nervous because you
don't know anyone or you've never been
to a conference before i want to
encourage you to step outside of your
comfort zone i remember the first time i
went to a conference i was so nervous i
didn't know who to talk to i didn't know
what to say i didn't even have a
business yet and i just remember that
there was this feeling there was this
energy when i was in that room it was
like the person i was sitting next to
i'm still friends with today actually
and her and i were able to geek out on
the same thing you know it's like it's
like you find instant friends because
you're talking about the same thing i
mean to be in a room with over a
thousand people who are interested in
growing their personal brand with video
makes you extraordinary ordinary people
are not actually coming to a conference
to be a part of what is happening with
video in this next decade you're going
to be one of those people i know that
you're someone who wants to grow your
business who wants to grow your brand
and i'm gonna i'm gonna say that you've
got to be in that room if you're unable
to travel we're creating a virtual
experience for you but if you can make
it in the room in las vegas in may i
want to encourage you to get in the room
you can secure your ticket at
growwithvideolive.com we have limited
vip and we've even offered an additional
platinum day for you high level business
owner who wants to be in the room with
people who are well over millions of
subscribers 10 million tick tock
followers and have earned in eight
figures of online course sales and
different levels of entrepreneurs so you
can secure whatever level works for you
at growthvideolive.com now every single
week you know my favorite part is to get
to say thank you to someone from our
community who has rated and reviewed our
podcast this happens over on the app
apple podcast and you could go in and
just share with us what you love about
this show this helps us get this in
front of other content creators and
entrepreneurs just like you and so i
will encourage you to take two minutes
and go over and rate and review the
podcast today's review comes from
michael michael says heather is amazing
oh this is funny i didn't even know that
this is what i was gonna say but thank
you michael okay michael says heather is
amazing she is relatable friendly and
inspirational same with sean and the
content is super helpful practical and
always worth the time thank you so much
michael and i i'm honest i actually
didn't know that that was the one i was
going to read but thank you so much for
your encouraging words if you have not
already you can subscribe here on the
show by clicking the subscribe button on
youtube or wherever you consume this
content on and if you know someone who
needs to be growing on tick tock send
this episode to a friend share it out
there and help other people grow their
brand using video thank you so much for
listening and we'll catch it in the next
episode
[Music]
you